[Music]
and oh hell nah news oh you better not
submitted by Littlefinger who I know who
it is now [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm
watching it again [ __ ] you [ __ ] I don't
know what happened ok but [ __ ] you again
what you don't know Littlefinger is he
reminds me of all the nice guys of the
world who pretend huh do you hate him
yet or not I do I really do I don't like
him because they burn he's he's the one
he got up behind him he's like I told
you not to trust me yet did you see him
at Bohemian Rhapsody you guys are we
watched half of it really sucks the main
actor very good movie
here I hear a lot about that I couldn't
watch it is it Rami Malek Malek from mr.
robot mr. robot there's no story line
there's just random clips pieced
together there's no one driving story
like oh I always wanted to be a
basketball star there's none but yes a
bit of my little finger
the internet is [ __ ] pissed after a
man says quote 99.99% of Asians are
[ __ ] ugly
dude who said this well the Internet's
mad because this guy said so we don't
know yet but who's the one guy who cares
I really hope I want him to be Asian so
bad I know miss ken Jeong that statement
is funnier than it is offensive yeah
because of that I like it sir yeah like
come on man he's met all the Asians and
he comes in conclusion and I mean it's
like one of those things that people say
like all fat people are lazy it's just
one of those it's stupid ass sakes how
come they get so much attention cuz it's
so [ __ ] crazy I'm curious to see what
kind of Asian he thinks is attractive
now yeah what is that point one Purdue
1% that's the log that doesn't speak
English and just sucks your dick all the
time
that's an anime girl yeah you [ __ ]
sick [ __ ] yeah who is this why is it why
does their words have weight when CeeLo
green nobody nobody but me I'm not
looking
don't look over here it's an old body
like some [ __ ] troll say in the car all
of a sudden now it everyone's given it
attention yeah that's kind of the
situation oh who cares nobody looks like
I didn't see what these guys it's
usually ugly ass people - hmm that are
like always the most judgmental usually
a guy in a gym with a half cut off shirt
and a in a [ __ ] knife they see that
the gym I pictured him like in his room
you ever see that me more leg there's
like a fat ass do with like [ __ ]
[ __ ] up face in there and then like
he's like sitting there flipping the
channel and there's like a hog girl and
then she's skinny yeah he's all like nah
no ass but like it's like shut up stupid
and who motive like what motivated that
statement you know I feel like it's
there's a crush that he really liked and
that girls like he can buy an Asian guy
so that fools like whoo yeah so this
story here is about this guy named
Burnaby I see that's something like
that's a fool that would bully but his
name is Burnaby Burnaby is he a Winnie
the Pooh character all the door ie lad
sorry
why he lives in Riverside and he's
employed at Amazon so this all sports so
he was responding to which just I'd note
he's a gay man so at least there's
Asians out there look it was just funny
than this yeah so it's like these Asian
dudes those guys are hot yeah so what
does he say like 99% like this was the
tweet not all Asians look like this
99.99% of them are not attractive facts
are facts
dunno this guy so then he ended facts
are facts that's all money
with his own statistics determine what
is old stack 99.9 neighbors thanks to my
calculations is actually wrong but
you're ugly though yeah after everyone
started like going down it does feel
like a mustache looks like he's leopard
look this is dirty yeah he looks
Filipino yeah he looks Asian yeah we're
[ __ ] forties man this guy's crazy why
everybody in the moms is dragging me
because I said the whole if you look at
my post the one day everybody's been
talking about are pretty cute they are a
[ __ ] amazing they're like God Asians
are not ask you and if we still pissed
about but you're ugly though yeah I'm
not hating because my best friend's
Asian Oh God good-looking should be at
least 97 percent sure or in that side
look at what else you are pretty ugly if
you see Asians and Asians they make
their babies come up beautiful but she
each other and the ugliest guppy is
looking people in less way races that's
just facts are facts
every can say I'm ugly that's totally
fine but I'm not it just it's funny to
me that I became so [ __ ] idiot years
of monkeys is dumb it's not a fact
it's a [ __ ] opinion you [ __ ] [ __ ]
keeps emphasizing that's a fact and
that's a fact if you just look at that
race they're ugly as fat as [ __ ] and
that's a fact
and it's like no you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's an opinion I like that he's like
I don't know why you guys are so fit
really
and I feel bad because he would he
should know what it's like to be
discriminated against cuz he's a
minority I don't know what the [ __ ] he's
a double-whammy dude you're a double
minority man I wish we could call him
Brett man Rock so just to hear what his
yeah what you think what you think dude
I would love that
the devil posted up a video reasons
there had me dying laughing dude it was
on Twitter where he was doing the pulled
at his mom's started sweeping the [ __ ]
you thought I was trying to get my hole
one yeah mom [ __ ] up or whatever that
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] funny dude they
should have been cracking up there I
love to see how he's like grown he went
from like this shitty bedroom in the
backgrounds like this [ __ ] beautiful
opulent house like oh good for you
he's balling the [ __ ] out right now he
just makes me laugh dude he's such a
funny [ __ ] did he's one of those
guys like in school like it's like okay
it's too early for you to be loud but
it's hurt I still love you yeah you know
he's loud at 7:00 the more he seems like
one of those kids that are always on
like it's like oh man this guy has he's
like perfect for the internet dude
because like we get to pick and choose
moing we could be next to him United
mean or like see him so he also seemed
like he wakes up at 5:00 p.m. no he
wakes up at the crack of dawn yeah how
many hobby yeah to do is make him look
fabulous for high school I remember like
he was so beautiful like what he went to
school every day so you think he's one
of the 4:30 a.m. oh yeah absolutely for
a full face everyday heli-max me up all
I know he made me laugh that's it he's
funny
it's hard was he limit Hawaii and he
hates LA oh really
damn straight but he's here every month
the funny [ __ ] is like when people get
mad at idiots he's really just like he's
so stupid it's like dude he's like one
of those people if they died the world
may be a better place he's like it's
upside just really dumb haven't you
you're telling me you haven't seen
Asians and Asians know what he's
thinking he's like all I gotta do is get
all of these people to my neighborhood
and see that ugly ass Asian family over
there and they'll believe they all know
he's like you guys are lie
yourself it's insane because he also
lives in Riverside there are a lot of
Asians there that's probably what do you
see a lot of Asian gangs to do good luck
brother
stupider that's what he sees he sees
that and he's like Oh
Asians are so coy that's insane and the
funny thing to me is that he's so
surprised that people are insulted like
he's shocked like why are you guys mad
because he's a [ __ ] idiot and he
doesn't know the difference between fact
and opinion first of all he doesn't know
that get in he goes 99.99% he makes up
his own [ __ ] numbers and stats about
Shane he's one of those people like when
you call him out the first thing he'll
say is well it's my opinion and
everyone's allowed to have an opinion
and at radom of speech yeah before you
call them out it's faster effects
it's like your facts are facts people
haven't you seen me like we as Asians on
the streets Wow he probably thinks
people don't like him cuz he's gay but
they just don't like me cuz he's [ __ ]
yeah like him they just tolerate him at
this point
good I know I know look I know this
stuff my friend is Asian and his
family's ugly my friend is Asian his
family's ugly I've been to I've been to
their [ __ ] gatherings guys they're
ugly
so 99.99% agents I know are ugly as [ __ ]
I like how he was kind of turned on
talking about those guys up because yeah
but not all Asian guys were like them
they're they're amazing so this is
married and his husband please be eaten
holy [ __ ] please be agent no I don't
know what married this yeah so he was
also defending no stupid couple this one
of us are 100% if you're married to
somebody like that your intelligence has
to be really low yeah so you're just a
reflection of who you're with so if
you're staying with that / you're pretty
[ __ ] stupid yourself and you're
defending them you're just as dumb or
you're even worse I'm so then people
started digging through his Twitter
account oh my god I mean that's so scary
good and Facebook page and they found
more racist stuff oh well first of all
before you get there you tweeted this
out my name is Burnaby so you're telling
me you have never said anything racist
about anyone because we are public a
wait because we are public about it that
makes us bad now I just got more balls
than you ever will you don't really know
how to write a full sentence because we
are public about is not a full sentence
so you shouldn't end it with a period
you [ __ ] suck comma yeah
that makes us bad stupid so here's the
rape I want oh boy here we go sometimes
gonna cut thank you for that and black
people wonder why they get shoot alright
this is why and this is the uncle in me
I would burn this [ __ ] alive and she
and she ever dating any of my sister's
kids the [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] little kid you [ __ ] oh
my goodness cotton-picking black ugly
monthly looking [ __ ] what is this dude
like you see Latino or like name one
Latino name their kid Burnaby yeah how
you spell it is parents party hated them
[Music]
Bernie bring a bit why is it that black
people get shoot you know why it's could
we shoot yeah but see this is oh this
also just goes back to the fact that
he's like really he's actually just like
not all jokes aside he's actually just
really he really done like like doesn't
have like a really can't comprehend
things it's like when people don't know
that someone's just [ __ ] kind of not
there or stupid or even crazy and then
they say [ __ ] online right and everyone
get out big at all like outraged like
why they saying that and then they're
like oh he's [ __ ] stupid how did he
get this far without getting his [ __ ]
beat out of him in Riverside maybe he
has already maybe that's what he hates
maybe a bunch of Asians yeah Asians do
Asians dajun's dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]